okay so you see you don't see irrelevant
things that's most things you do see
things that move you forward and you do
see things that get in your way and in
the class of things that get in your way
are indeterminate occurrences novel or
anomalous occurrences and almost
everything that gets in your way is in
some sense a novel occurrence because
you usually structure your behavior so
that you don't go anywhere where
something wildly anomalous is likely to
occur so so know if you encountered an
obstacle two things happen at the same
time and one is that your movement
forward to your specific goal or sets of
goals is blocked but the second thing
that happens is you're faced with a
mystery and the mystery is this thing
wasn't supposed to exist but it does
exist
so what implication does that have for
everything I think and that's very very
hard on people they do not like that at
all and no wonder because it's it's it's
the constrained chaos that's underneath
everything inhibited by your contextual
knowledge that suddenly popped its head
up into your world it's like it's like
the shark in the movie Jaws which is of
course a mythological story it's exactly
that and and and it's exactly what that
movie signified a safe vacations
paradise
all of a sudden threatened by some
subterranean thing that can pull you
down and and that destroys the peace and
the harmony of that particular community
two dragons story it's a hero myth it's
it's a story that people have been
telling forever so so and what you can
think you can think of that thing that
remark that rises up from the depths or
that whale or that dragon or that
predator or the foreign invader for that
matter or the Barbarian they all fit
into the same category
that's what had been deemed irrelevant
suddenly manifesting itself and when you
think about how much is deemed
irrelevant the fact that it suddenly
manifests itself that's exactly the
purpose for the reason for the for the
trauma it's like well I've eradicated
from my conceptualizations 99.99% of
everything it's zeroed out and all of a
sudden I've made a mistake
I don't know where I am well what's
relevant when you don't know where you
are and the answer that is since you
don't know everything is relevant and
you can imagine the sort of terror that
people who experience paranoid
schizophrenia are living in perennial E
because what happens to them is
precisely that they undergo neuro
physiological transformations that makes
everything that they once depended on
disappear and everything comes back is
relevant and that puts them in the early
stages of schizophrenia that's
extraordinarily stressful neural
physiologically so they're overwhelmed
with cortisol and their brains
deteriorate as a consequence of that
it's just too much so and surprisingly
right because you can't deal with you
can hardly deal with anything let alone
with everything now and often what you
see and it's rarely conceptualized this
way in the training of of clinical
therapists but often what you see when
you are dealing with people who are in
crisis isn't people who have a mental
illness in fact in my experience that's
actually quite rare what's far more
common is that the person that you're
talking to has become overwhelmed by
catastrophe so their life has fallen
apart in some way that makes what
they're doing actually impossible you
know so maybe someone very close to them
in their family that they were depending
on has developed a very serious illness
and that's throwing their entire
financial state into utter chaos or
maybe they've developed a condition that
makes it impossible for them to work or
you know you can you can imagine the
potential range of catastrophes and
they're coming to see you because
they're anxious and depressed but the
reason they're anxious and depressed is
because everything they have ignored has
popped its head back up and is hell-bent
on their destruction and often you see
people who are being attacked by five or
six of these monsters at the same time
and it isn't their mental illness that
stops them from being able to deal with
it although that's you know whatever
weaknesses you have are going to
interfere it's the fact that what
they're facing is no damn joke and if
you were facing it you'd feel exactly
the same way so then you're trying to
come up with practical solutions to
these tremendously complex problems and
that's a very
very well it's extraordinarily difficult
generally speaking people often don't
come to a therapist until they've
exhausted their entire range of
resources they cannot figure out what to
do and so you know in a situation like
that you can administer antidepressants
and maybe that will help the person
increase their stress resistance but as
a and it may be that because they're
depressed and have been brought down
that they are in fact exaggerating the
danger of some of the smaller monsters
that are after them but making the
person more stress resilient doesn't
give them for example a new job and it
certainly doesn't bring back the person
they've been living with for two years
who has a degenerating neurological
disease or some form of cancer but these
things are major you know I often see
people who well they're in a
relationship maybe they're rather
isolated older older people one of the
partners is dying in their entire
financial situation that has become
catastrophic it's like that's not a
mental illness man I mean they may have
got into that situation because of one
inadequacy or another but you don't even
want to push that too far because that
sort of thing can happen to anyone
and and will in fact happen to most
people in one form or another at least
at some point in their lives so you want
to be damned prepared for that you want
to be prepared for that because it's
bitter and and harsh and anxiety
provoking and painful but if you're not
ready that it's also held and often you
can stop things from becoming hell even
though you can't stop them from being
bitter and painful and anxiety provoking
and all of that you can at least delimit
the catastrophe enough so that it
doesn't permanently bring you and the
people around you down and that stuff's
not so bad right that's a hell are at
least it's a lot better than the
alternative so this is the problem you
know things object things are obstacles
well how big is the obstacles the same
it's the same question as how big is the
predator that's lurking outside the door
of our cave it's exactly the same
problem except construct conceptualized
abstractly and I would say exactly the
same systems that you're gifted
ancestors used to conceptualize the
lurking predator
are the systems that are activated now
when you encounter the re-emergence of
all the monsters that you've ignored
it's the same neurological platform you
think well how could it be otherwise
because evolution is a conservative
process everything about you is built on
on ancient foundations right very little
new certainly very little radically new
comes into existence it's mostly
tinkering with structures that have been
around forever like your body plan for
example that's unbelievably old I mean
you share that with you share that with
lizards roughly speaking so it's
incredibly ancient